سنعود اليها للتعليق على الاخبار العاجله
الى النقل عن مراسل جزيره قذائف صاروخيه
تنطلق من قطاع غزه اتجاه مواقع ومصادرات
اسرائيليه متاخمه للقطاع هذه اخر التطورات
الان نقلا عن مراسل الجزيره قذائف صاروخيه
تنطلق من قطاع غزه تجاه مواقع ومستوطنات
اسرائيليه متاخمه للقطاع وكانت نجوان قد
تحدثت عن صافرات الانذار تدوي في الشريط
الحدودي مع قطاع غزه والمدن القريبه من
هناك اذا كانت نجوان سمري جاهزه نعود
اليها اليك الكلمه
حتى الان لا يوجد اي تقريب رسمي من قبل
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه ومن قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي بشان صافرات الانذار لم
يتم الاعلان حتى هذه اللحظه فكان بالفعل
تم سقوط قضائف في مستوطنات خلاف في غزه او
اذا تم جدار
القضاء من خلال منظومه قبه
القبعه الحديديه القبعه الدفاعيه لكن
وفق شهود عيان ووفق ما يصدر في وسائل
الاعلام في اسرائيل
تحديدا في منطقه
في مستوطنه في قطاع في القرب من قطاع غزه
هذه المعلومات المتوفره في هذه اللحظات
الانذار في عده مواقع في منطقه غلاف غزه
تحديدا في منطقه
الزيروت والان هناك حديث عن سماع ذوي
انفجارات قد تكون بطبيعه الحال انفجارات
لاعتراض منظومه
القبه الحديديه لهذه القذائف التاريخيه
التي اطلقت
غزه وقد تكون سقطت في اماكن معينه بهذه
المنطقه حتى الان لم يتم الاعلان او
الحديث
موتى ثقافه
في وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه تظهر اعتقاد
حديديه لبعض القذائف الصاروخيه في سماء
غلاف غزه اذا هي هي بالفعل كان هناك اطلاق
الصواريخ وكان هناك اعتراض هذا وفقه لبعض
الفيديوهات التي بدات تنشر في مواقع
التواصل وفي بعض المواقع
العبريه
ولكن حتى الان لم يصدر اي بيان رسمي بشان
هذه القضاء من قبل الجيش وصلت
كما ذكرت نجوان اذا هذه صور للرشقات
واعتراض القبه القبه الحديديه لها اذا
مجموعه من الصواريخ اطلقت في سبيروت وتم
اعتراضها من قبل القبه الحديديه نتابع هذه
اللقطات اذن الصور الاولى التي تاتي
الان لاعتراض القبه الحديديه لبعض الرشقات
الصاروخيه التي اطلقت باتجاه
استيروت وتم اعتراضها من قبل القبه
الحديديه كما ذكرت نجوى